anything that you do definitely has the
element of power when you're actually
out there again she broke them again she
walked in and the beat is taking you
then you just go for it
my name is Keith Holt when I'm out at
the balls I become chief Avenue at the
Crown Prince of Baltimore
voguing it's an underground art form
that was brought to like throw shade on
the dance floor ballroom in general was
developed to be underground fortunately
because of so much stigma and hate that
the LGBTQ community have this furnace
this is a place that you can be anything
you want to be James is like that new
generation Lucas how you doing I'm the
legendary little James Caan I'm the vote
femme extraordinaire he is like the
Beyonce of the water I'm saying look who
is my best friend I am the voice of
Baltimore look miss rahi the dramatic
one he commentates people James mug and
myself are some people that are really
leading the next generation I work for
the Baltimore City Health Department I'm
the youth outreach coordinator with that
I've kind of come up with the different
events and something that kept coming up
was why not throw a ball so we have our
free ball because Baltimore has a high
rate in HIV that's why we make sure that
every even that we have we do offer both
HIV testing and HIV linkage to treatment
as well for me it's really like this is
not just a job this is my community
these are people that I know ballroom is
not just extracurricular activity
anymore it's actually a part of my life